-So, last night, Meghan Markle
was interviewed by Oprah,
and I wanted to do
a whole piece about it,
but we ran out of time.
-Well, how much time do we have?
-One minute.
-That's all the time I need.
-Start the clock!
-First of all, if you though
they were gonna come on TV
and not really spill the tea
then you would be wrong as butt,
because they said everything
So, like, they were both like,
"It's not the Queen
who was racist.
It's this group of people
who run the monarchy
called the firm,"
and I was like,
"Are you talking about
that rap group
with Nas and Foxy Brown in it?
Then I don't know
who "the firm" is.
Also, someone here is racist
and it's not
the ancient white woman?
Okay.
-41 seconds!
-So, Meghan said that
when tabloids said that
she made Kate cry,
that that was a lie.
Kate really was the one
who made her cry.
But no one in the monarchy
stood up for her.
Can you stand it?!
-31 seconds!
-Okay, so Meghan Markle said
"When I was pregnant
with Archie, people were
concerned about how dark
the baby would be."
And Oprah was like,
"Who said that?"
And she was like,
"I will not say."
And you best believe that wa
the right thing to do,
because let me catch who sai
that and see what happens.
-You're gonna run out of time!
-I can make it! I can make it!
Okay, they took away
their security detail.
And then of all the people
in the entire world,
it was Tyler Perry who let the
stay in his house.
Harry got cut off!
They're having
a little, bitty baby girl!
Piers Morgan is insane now
and will be forever!
-That's it!
Amber Ruffin, everybody.
Give it up for Amber.
[ Light applause ]
And now she's going to
slowly scoot away.
Oh, no, she's not. Alright
[ Laughter ]